hey guys Dimitri from the score esports
now dota 2 is one of the most
sophisticated and intricate games in
existence one where creativity and
foresight are often just as important as
mechanical skill and while it's easy to
get caught up in mesmerizing teamfights
and flashy solo kills some of the game's
most impressive moments aren't about
fighting at all they're about
outsmarting and outmaneuvering your
opponent by escaping certain death
[Music]
Moochie
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so grab a teepee and stay in the trees
cuz this week were counting down the top
ten Jukes in the history of competitive
dota 2 coming in at number 10 is demon
with a slick brewmaster Juke during the
group stage of dream League season for
using brew masters drunken haze Jimmy
was able to keep his blink dagger from
being disabled and use it to escape
certain death he then casually walked
over to the side shop to purchase a
teleport scroll before blinking again
and retreating back home to forget the
crush my cat turns up with the arrow
onto Jimmy Jimmy is in a bit of trouble
now the episodes trying again himself
are they may lose team and hit demon
first at the drunken haze he's gonna try
and look to walk into the ocean but
there is no roshan side in themselves to
break out because of the miss Paik cat
couldn't get the damage in well Jimmy
will have a break again in a few seconds
and you should be at the big TV the air
is gonna be on it does it again demons
out for clovers there Jimmy's happy
report coming in at number 9 is sumail
and his famous puck escape against
planet odd from epicenter 2017 and
bottom Lane sumail go silent stunt if
they laid a nice little trap for him
he's pretty tanky though sumail fairly
high level but toxic
jenia rage with the static storm no
sumail making out the substrate gonna
find any phase shifts again dodge his
jewels are smashed and he escaped the
package times well then she does he make
it he's still trying this
you gotta be using phase shift blink
dagger and use scepter in the perfect
order
sumail was able to avoid death by joking
out his opponents in a way that you
would expect from a TI champion he has
like man I hit that prediction son
strike that it still coming in at number
eight is I and his slippery elder Titan
Juke during the International 2016's
quarterfinals Evil Geniuses vs newbee
after a massive teamfight near the Rosh
pit zai found himself running for his
life as one of the last two remaining
members of Evil Geniuses battling up
against AI but the damage from fear is
threatening his life he's got to lift
that reach and come into play
same kind fear around as best as
possible sigh the player had this worst
ap trying to choke out the pro strike he
knows his coming did he just do it I
love this job
Katie before staff that subway plates
back in dancing in and out of the Rosh
pit I I was able to buy just enough time
for his four staff to come off cooldown
he then forced himself to the high
ground before sidestepping KPS
burrowstrike versus well their butts hi
what an unbelievable play right here is
he Jukes into the Roshan Paige I think
an awful huge sigh just Jukes him out of
his shoes right now coming in at number
seven is matam Inspector Juke from the
Kyiv major in a quarterfinals nail-biter
Invictus gaming attempted a smoke gank
that ended in disaster as they were
unable to start the fight on their own
terms
xxs gets the lead in special someone
like the th is gonna be pretty to talk
cuz we kept up which was good to
remember actually go out Jupiter left
off make it
better but being the first to break a
G's smoke matumbo man used hans and
frantically jumped between illusions
confusing xxs and forcing him to duel an
illusion by mistakes yeah that dude
there with the whole growing xxs of God
forcing him to jewel of entually an
illusion coming in at number six is an
iconic moment courtesy of wheeze
timbersaw and OD pixels always
impressive play-by-play in the opening
game of dream league season sevens Grand
Finals we took on every team liquid
player by himself joking around using
timber chain while also using Lotus orb
and you'll cept her to keep himself
alive
take it away OD from A to Z looks to
take that money kuroky to a lot of time
being we are just over the Shiva stop
it's not gonna clip on to Kuro he'll
survive mind control traps up misery has
the concept of the time being is not
gonna be enough to save him the Sun
strike connects miseries down planet out
there lost two we are still tally pretty
strong can liquid bring down the timber
it'll lower throw down the Silas they've
got the book cause he removes it with
the limiters Jules is himself can he
blame himself bad truck hit his way out
of the tree line
he definitely loves collects buddies
[Music]
the groom will survive but the biggest
survive is the fact that we are he's
still alive in this situation set high
me miracle daddy continued to play
around the Simba
he's I give up Luke to set up for the
tornado but we huh side steps to the
side knees sit back up wcvb come in for
resolution we are still has to survive
for a bit more time before the backup
there here comes the j-th I put up my
river itself straighten on the Shakers
head takes down the shaker we are still
there Brittney's return of resolution
supports a BKB looks towards the side
try to bat against the tip of a Brazil
the man he carries himself we have
continued to chase a flight control as
the bounty route if you want citizen
agency skippers life attack again with
the self fuels Japan Super Center set my
dog the Sun is falling through receivers
[Music]
takes down
[Music]
for this liquid builders in the ball
chase down we are with this imitate
guess the double kill and put it on
outside yet what a game is this
beautiful I just know when they're
ending survive coming in at number five
is maybe next time and his ridiculous
Monkey King Juke during the winners
final of elimination mode 3og threw
everything they had at this Monkey King
but ended up going on a wild goose chase
instead and while OG were busy trying to
catch MNT the rest of add phenom pushed
an uncontested bottling command and a
troll why did you do something are you
are you watching this is ridiculous yeah
sure thing I've ever seen this fan
teammates are you kidding me this is
some Benny Hill music stuff right here
house is still happening their control
figure they're like what is happening
push bottom everybody points bottom
they're not here they have to TP home
maybe next time wasted maybe a minute
and a half of their time and the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen
coming in at number four is faith
beyonds brewmaster escape against
digital chaos during the group stage of
star series season 3 backup things were
looking grim for wings after losing
blinks invoker outside their base and
with no buyback available wings had no
choice but to give up their bottom Lane
bear with the looming threat of also
losing their mid lane barracks faith
beyond an ice ice teleported to the top
lane in a desperate attempt to force
digital chaos back home to defend that
they see pop they say that I tried to
read it out the plan worked brilliantly
as faith beyond was able to narrowly
escaped death while buying enough time
for his invoker to respawn oh but top
lane
[Music]
okay do it faith beyond proving once
again that you can never ever get on his
level is moon meander and his hilarious
book shot Juke against the sea is
rejects during the MLG World Finals EU
qualifier after losing miracles
anti-mage moon took it upon himself to
take his enemies on a lengthy trip
around the map wasting their time in the
process he needs to be able to get some
sort of hook shot opening he's looking
towards middle lane he's out not only
did he distract his opponents long
enough for miracle to respawn but he
also managed to make it out alive in the
end
dear moon he's gonna be losing the
agents here oh shut up
go away Lance he catches him you
again they slow them down
moving around the map camp all right
easy campus pick a bomb and always what
a fly he is on the mark here keeps on
blinking forward you'll scepter draws
them up a little bit more clockwork has
four staff has another hookshot
turned it around where are you gonna go
the greenways coming Hoka Wade right
side DD out he's out oh my goodness
oh god what a clown the fence that one
was coming in at the runner-up spot is
miracle and his iconic morphling
illusion bait during the semi-finals of
MDL winter 2015
using a manta illusion as bait miracle
drew out multiple Ultimates from LGD
while also netting a three witch doctor
kill for his troubles
[Music]
there's no way I mean they couldn't kill
him actually [ __ ] oh let's watch that
play again this time with the Russian
casters coming in at the number one spot
is miracle yet again with a truly iconic
Juke this time with shadow Feeny
on the brink of defeat Alliance were
desperate to kill miracle shadow fiend
for what was possibly their only chance
at staying in the game and it looked as
if they were about to do just that as
limp caught liquid superstar Kari just
as he was trying to TV away anyway oh my
god he's getting the career Oh what is
happening another relocating it to try
to move up he doesn't that boost food
travel up and good here beautiful
my god he actually elusive baits them
and Enza he's gonna take your teeth he's
got the pod well guys that's our list be
sure to LIKE the video subscribe to our
Channel and let us know in the comments
what other dota 2 related top tens you'd
like to see see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else
head up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]